um can you tell me uh how how nervous
were you the first time back in the day
because I was just talking to my boy and
we were trying to go over we were
talking about how Roxy and big TIG are
very slept on in terms of when we talk
about the the best host of Port
Elizabeth because everyone says Adrian
free and I'm like Roxy and Tig did their
thing too but how nervous were you the
very first time going on 106 and Park
like were you nervous like what was that
day like pulling up to 106th and park
bro I think it's more anxious because
it's your peers you know what I'm saying
it's like 106 apart I felt like I was
going back to high school and seeing all
my peers like you going to audience they
got people your age yes kids it was like
like Teenage [__] [__] in the crowd
it's like you it feels like a party like
you know what I'm saying so I wasn't
nervous it was just more anxious to like
and exciting and [__] because this is
like I don't even know if they have they
don't even have shoes like that no more
like I just watched a random performance
pop up on my story of like [__] was fun
man it was when you when you went to 106
it was like a reunion it was like an
event yeah I saw do you remember when
genuine performed and they had to
respond it was like
so main one is out it's going crazy it's
featuring Tyga it's uh it's featuring
Lil Wayne
um are you gonna have any uh sort of uh
obviously like you got 3 000 unreleased
songs so that's you know it's crazy
Jesus uh you already have the next
single pick though no no no I don't have
any pick I like to stay fresh bro like
I'm going in the lab and cooking for
that would you like these next few shows
I'm probably lacking in it just would
you ever uh reunite with the uh Scott
Storage here for sure yeah I talked to
Scott two weeks ago we got records that
could possibly be something you know
what I'm saying already but we
definitely tap it back in for sure I'll
just talk to him a lot of cigarette
smoke in that session bro Scott yo Scots
he'll smoke down them cigs and then he's
a he's you know what's crazy well he in
the studio with me he don't really he
don't really smoke he'll go outside the
studio no no he'll smoke outside I don't
smoke weed and smoke cigarettes like
that I see him smoking weed I'm smoking
and he'll smoke cigarettes I don't see
him smoke cigarettes George is a
sweetheart man he's a great guy I can't
wait for the to make
the movie about his life crazy because
it's gonna be in [__] insane I don't
even want it to be a movie I want it to
be like a HBO Max original it's it's
something legendary I want 50 Cent to be
the executive producer like the sky
storage store that could be fire because
he had sex with everybody first
everybody like Ray J did not hit it
first time Scott Storage anyway